so how much would you pay for the
ultimate in game controller
customization would you pay a hundred
dollars what about 150 because that's
how much the xbox elite controller costs
a hundred and fifty dollars and yeah
that's a lot but the elite controller
offers more customization over anything
I've ever seen first off this thing is
dead sexy it's got a real nice way to it
more so than the existing Xbox one
controller it feels great in my hands
not to mention it's got a smooth
rubberized coating throughout and it's
just a really slick and smooth looking
controller ok so the customization
that's the focal point on the controller
the elite ships with three sets of
stainless steel analog sticks each
bearing in height and tip design you can
even mix and match each to your heart's
content there's also two types of deep
heads as well one traditional plus shape
and another octagon looking thing that
should help hitting those directional
diagonals best of all everything's
magnetic the d-pads and sticks easily
swap out with one another even the
triggers can be modified each has a
switch that lets you alternate between
full and hair trigger mode the latter of
which stops you from having to pull the
trigger all the way down then there's
the interchangeable back pedals these
are small little levers that allow you
to enter a command using just your
middle finger around back now you need
to program these with a free app for
Xbox one which lets you assign any
controller input to those back pedals
you can even remap the entire controller
to microsoft says that developer design
control schemes will be available for
the elite all accessible through that
xbox one app there's a switch on the
controller as well and that'll let you
go back and forth
between two loaded profiles not a huge
fan of those backpedals I mostly played
with them removed but some players love
them because you can bind them to car
controls or use them as a quicker way to
access something like a grenade toss or
melee I just found myself hitting them a
lot by accident so I didn't use finally
the elite controller will also work with
Windows 10 and it will even work
wirelessly if you buy a $25 adapter but
the question you've got to be asking is
is this worth 150 dollars well that
depends right the elite costs more than
twice the amount of a regular controller
and you could argue it has more than
twice the amount of features but is it
twice as better probably not not really
sure competitive players will likely
love this because of the endless amount
of customization and those twitch
controls we talked about now if that
stuff doesn't mean much to you then the
elite shouldn't be your go-to controller
but for $150 you are getting a
top-of-the-line fully customizable and
gorgeous controller that can work on PC
and Xbox one